à tour cette fois des policiers
sanctionnés pour des propos qualifiés
d'inappropriés et discriminatoires sur
un groupe WhatsApp après enquête interne
ils ont reçu un avertissement soit le
premier degré de sanctions c'est un
policier stagiaire qui avait révélé ses
propos à sa hiérarchie en début d'année
que sait-on justement du contenu de ces
messages les précisions avec Lucas
c'est un policier stagiaire licencié
pour insuffisance professionnelle qui a
dénoncé l'effet en cause une
conversation WhatsApp alimentée par des
agents de police secours et sur laquelle
sont envoyés nombre de blagues et
d'images de mauvais goût certains
échanges revêtent même d'un caractère
islamophobe comme cette image tournant
en temps dérision une jeune femme
amputée d'une jambe plus morbide encore
selon une source proche du dossier des
photos de cadavres circuleraient dans un
communiqué le préfet d'Indre-et-Loire
confirme les faits reproché aux
participants de cette conversation nommé
groupes de en référence à une unité
d'intervention de la police de Tours des
investigations réalisées il est ressorti
que les échanges entre les
fonctionnaires étaient inappropriés et
pouvait revêtir une connotation
discriminatoire à la suite de l'enquête
les policiers concernés ont reçu un
avertissement contacté les syndicats de
police n'ont pas souhaité réagir
évoquant certaines zones d'ombres autour
du dossier